meeting on February the 18th ministers
in charge of Europe's finances will take
stock of negotiations with the European
Parliament on the establishment of a
common mechanism for rescuing failing
banks in a drive to avoid any repetition
of taxpayer-funded bailouts the
so-called single resolution mechanism is
a key element of Europe's banking Union
and ministers are working hard to reach
an agreement with the European
Parliament before the end of the
parliaments current term in May the
European Central Bank will present to
the ministers its first quarterly report
on the implementation of the single
supervisory mechanism which was
established in October the council will
also discuss and most likely endorse the
Commission's annual growth survey which
asked member states to continue growth
friendly fiscal consolidation tackling
unemployment and modernizing public
administration as part of a set of
measures to continue correcting economic
imbalances and consolidate the incipient
economic recovery EU finance ministers
are also expected to set priorities for
the EU s budget for 2014 and adopt a
recommendation on the budget discharge
for 2012 setting a common position in
view of the forthcoming g20 finance
meeting is also on the agenda